Residing in Japan is the Jigokudani Monkey Park.
The area is very cold, resulting in frozen grounds.
However, a unique aspect of the park is the boiling water,...
...which bubbles up from cracks in the ground's surface.
The park is referred to as "Hell's Valley" due to the hot springs and surrounding steep cliffs.
It has an elevation of nearly 2,790 feet,...
...and snow covers the ground for roughly four months of the year.
The harsh environment keeps it generally uncrowded when it comes to humans.
However, monkeys find the park to be a haven.
Japanese macaques, also known as snow monkeys, inhabit the park...
...commonly gathering around a man-made pool near the entrance.
The monkeys usually stick together, staying in large groups...
...and they have become accustomed to human guests.
The monkeys mostly ignore people, but allow them to get close-up views.
The large population of Japanese macaques descends from the cliffs to reside in the park...
...during the days of the winter months in order to bathe in the hot springs.
During the evening hours, they return to the safety of the nearby forests.
These red-faced, long-haired monkeys calmly relax or play in the pools,...
...which seem to serve as jacuzzis to them.